there's two kinds of kids the kids
should eat it like this or the kids that
eat like this
so girl
hi everyone i'm somi and i'm here to
share my favorite snacks
[Music]
[Applause]
ooh
take
their way first and it has vanilla ice
cream inside since 1946
wow
[Music]
it's my guilty pleasure number one
[Music]
huh
it's so cool oh my god
super classic
but i wanted to share this because it's
super og in korea and people would stand
in line to get this just gonna have a
bite because i have a lot more to go
ketchup i did not know this was a
canadian thing i thought everyone loved
lee's ketchup i would usually eat them
when i go to canada to visit my family
there so
my roots are here
i love these you cannot find them
anywhere in korea really
oh
oh this
vinegary
ketchup oh i love see tangy i love it
because it's tangy and it's sweet and
it's ketchup
i'm getting goosebumps seriously oh my
god i feel that i'm canadian when i say
a
it just comes and goes like it pops out
out of nowhere i'm like it's good eh or
oh my god you can't find these anywhere
eh like i would say a here and there
i'm gonna save these for later
oh
my favorite okay i have these since i
was like five
i mean this is super og too i brought
korean snacks okay you might you guys
might freak out yes it looks like a fish
but it is not a fish it is red bean
paste pancake
it's called
they only sell this in the winter times
but people in korea they're crazy over
this it's a bunga
and
i love these so much it's so crispy
so but if it comes
excuse me if you come to korea in the
winter times please
look for these find them and try them
they're so good
my love my fiance my guilty pleasure
number two
flamin hot cheetos i would eat this
after
a long long day or a very hard day i
would
just be quiet all the way home just grab
these and munch munch munch
yeah i love these
so when i have my kpop idol friends home
i would be like hey you gotta try this
one and i'll give it to them and they'll
be like oh my god where'd you get it
they go crazy over this
this is going under the table
this is a snack that i have since i was
a baby
it's called push-up
it means crush it crush it and it's a
ramen cracker so you'll break it in half
and you know kids could be aggressive so
they'll go like
and then you open it up like nothing
happens
and put all the seasoning in there
and you'll shake it
a lot of noise
i mean it's so good i can eat this all
day
the tip of eating this is you gotta eat
it till the end and you have to go like
this and eat all the seasoning and the
little crumbs that's the best part
[Music]
okay this is called taito pai
it's chocolate covered with mochi and
covered in chocolate
this is actually something fancy it's
kind of pricey but it's really good
you see the mochi layer
i would say it's like
a korean style snickers
i ate these since i was a kiddo i really
like combos and especially the buffalo
blue cheese because i'm extra and this
is super super extra
[Applause]
i used to go to a foreign school when i
was a kid
so
i would have friends that live in the
army base and i would go to the army
base to the commissary and i'll buy all
the
u.s snacks
and that's why my favorite snacks are
kind of
old it's not new so i like combos lays
twizzlers
nerds something like sweet tarts but
this brings me way back
sugar hard
this
is
tokuchi it's rice cakes and you deep fry
it and you put spicy and sweet sauce
around it this used to be something you
i would eat after school there's two
kinds of kids
the kids should eat it like this
a one by one or the kids that you like
this like one two three five at once
like
[Music]
huh
so girl
crab
no more zombie no more
[Music]
oh that's it
oh
thank you guys for watching i had a
blast i had so much fun
and please look forward to my upcoming
crazy news
and go watch any more of the music video
and xoxo and dum dum
love
you
yay
[Music]
you